this is a production of Cornell
University
so yeah so it's a pretty broad topic and
we're I'm going to present a piece of it
that we've been working on and by we I
mean there's been a group of us and it
really is a group effort and that's
myself Liz Carter Susan Rhea and Steve
Shaw with input from Peter Woodbury and
I should say that there were several
groups around the world that are that
are really doing great work in this area
now we had a seminar a couple weeks ago
from a person from Australia scott
chapman who is it with CSIRO and he's
associated with a group at University of
Queensland net it's really doing great
work on on trying to help agricultural
producers and Australia deal with
impacts of climate and that's important
there and so so y maes y climate impacts
and how do we get involved so the kind
of global answer to the first question
is mazes a big crop it's the leading
cereal crop in the world demand supposed
to increase by fifty percent over the
next 50 or 75 years and over that time
temperatures are supposed to be
increasing bite at least two or three
degrees C potentially so that's kind of
the overarching reason and why climate
impacts because we're expecting these
increases in temperature and and we
don't potentially changes in
precipitation there's been a number of
papers over the past ten years primarily
from folks who are not their primary
areas not agriculture where they have
done yield projections using statistical
modeling and they have really they've
suggested pretty severe impacts of
increasing temperatures on maize
productivity both historically but also
in particular into the future several
years ago Susan and Steve kind of looked
into this and had some questions about
the methodologies and results and that
led to a paper where they did some
initial
work on looking at Yura gated maize
production to see whether they could
detect a temperature impact on on
irrigated maize and they were unable to
in the in the data they looked at but
that led to a hatch proposal that that
was funded and allowed us to look more
in you know intensive Lee at the impact
of climate on maize with particular
emphasis on temperature but it kind of
evolved into additional additional
impacts so I'm just going to try to go
through some of the kind of climate
impacts on maize maze yields so the cap
on yields is solar radiation and so I
don't have that here but that given
location for any given soil is going to
be solar radiation but the next most
important impact despite all the
emphasis on temperature actually is
precipitation I think every most
agronomists and crop physiologists would
agree that that's the main limitation
climate limitation on on maize
production so i got this quote from Tom
Sinclair the thousand pound gorilla and
crop response to climate change he's
referring to precipitation as probably
because maybe to emphasize that you know
it's it's precipitation more than the
more recent emphasis on temperature but
also the fact that we don't projections
of precipitation are really uncertain so
we really don't know what's going to
happen that's going to have a major
impact but there are direct in
temperature impacts on maize and
probably the most well-documented is on
phenology that means higher temperatures
accelerated rate of development reduced
cumulative intercepted radiation in
lower yields and that's been that's been
pretty well documented they're also our
physiological impacts reduce pollen
viability loss of membrane integrity
inactivation of some heat sensitive
enzymes particularly in photosynthesis
and in starch synthesis and increased
respiration but those you know the
temperature it's 38 to 40
degrees c and keep that in mind because
we'll be getting coming back to that in
a bit there are what have been proposed
these indirect temperature impacts and
primarily that's that there's going to
be an increase in the backward demand
it's going to cause more frequent bouts
of water stress in maize and reduce
heels I'm going to actually spend a fair
amount of time on that and I'll get like
I'll get back to that in a bit there are
complications and that's these
interactions for climate the internet
the problem is is that high temperature
drought higher high evaporated demand
are all highly correlated they often at
least in the US corn belt there they
occur all at the same time so it becomes
very difficult then to isolate which are
the factors are most responsible for
impacts on yield and that's something
that Liz is been wrestling with quite a
bit recently the second thing and I'm
not going to really talk about this but
it's I think pretty important is there's
not really clear from a Jean when maize
is under water stress how will higher
temperatures impact yield in other words
is what kind of interaction is there
when the crop is already in stressed
from one safes a drought how will then
elevated temperatures haven't what
additional impact will they have and
that's something that there's not a lot
of literature on and the literature
that's there is not real clear on that
but it's important because it'll you
know it'll give information on what are
the impacts on the thresholds for damage
from say temperature or or water stress
so just to kind of do a very simple very
brief kind of overview of my sense of
the literature the more recent
literature that I mentioned on
statistical modeling is there was first
an early focus on temperature and this
was to d2 in precipitation or drought
was considered secondary in this
in these studies and they report pretty
significant impacts both historically
and in projected into the future as I
mentioned what note the thresholds that
they were using to where they expected
damage to occur reduce yields was around
30 degrees C that's in contrast to the
to what we saw before for the
physiological damage more recently they
I think as they become became associated
with more agriculturally oriented people
let's say they shifted their emphasis to
that the impact of higher temperatures
climate change was going to be by
increasing evaporated demand as I
mentioned before and this this is
something that we're again they're
projecting pretty significant impacts
and this is I'm going to try to get to
this and explain it a little bit better
and I hope I'll be able to do that
because we have some serious we have
some questions about that also on these
more recent kind of statistical studies
they've understood that there's
acclimation that occurs in maize to high
temperatures that could modify or
mitigate the impact of temperature
there's also one has to account for
genetics management and soil factors and
that there are impacts by growth stage
these genetic management and soil
factors are really important because
they not only impact yield independently
of climate but they interact with
climate to to to affect maize yields and
another quote from Sinclair at I thought
was quite good is right here temperature
increase imposed on current crop systems
without management or genetic changes
raw is often predicted to decrease
yields but it is highly likely that
cropping systems will remain static and
I think I'll be able to show some day
it's often predicted but is highly well
he was saying that there they'll remain
static the deals won't be affected the
temperature they're projecting decrease
actually it's a good I'm glad you
brought that up here
because actually we can I think we can
show at least in some of our data that
management can actually increase yields
even with increases in temperature so
these are going to go through a series
of questions and to try to address this
and the climate impacts and and this one
on the VP DS I just wanted to say right
now there's two aspects to this impact
of vpd on on on maize yields or increase
evaporated van one is whether they're
actually will be an increase into the
future in the US corn belt and the
second is how if there is what is the
interaction between BPD and the
processes of interest that would be a
vapid transpiration and carbon
assimilation amazed so I'm going to try
to get to that and hopefully it will be
little clearer so this first question we
address by using statistical modeling of
both irrigated and rain-fed Mays yields
and i'll get to that just second that's
work that liz has been primarily
involved with and in fact gave a seminar
last spring on the irrigated component
that so the avenge we had here is we had
access to a data set from the National
Corn Growers Association for both
irrigated and rain-fed of categories or
classes this was from 2005 to 2012 it
was focused mainly in the Western Corn
Belt but in the rain fed we included
Iowa also we have other additional
States we haven't started in that the
analyses on those this is under so the
advantage is its optimal management so
the limitations on yield are going to be
due to whatever the local factors like
soils might be but other than that it's
going to be a climate impact and that's
what we're really trying to get at was
what is the impact of client
there were a large number of values
yield data that we had and then we had
the the real nice thing is we had all
this additional information so this is
both management and genetics information
that was really quite useful and trying
to explain the impacts on on maize
yields both in irrigated and in the rain
fed datasets and those were used to
define growth stages that were used that
we use to both look at seasonal impacts
but also impacts by growth stage again
Liz Gabe gave a seminar on the irrigated
part of this work and the main findings
there is that where was evidence for
acclamation there was no impacts of
temperature with even in 2012 when we
had near record or record temperatures
across the u.s. corn belt there was also
evidence that by agronomically realistic
adjustments of management you could
actually increase yields so there was
room for for actually improved yields in
the irrigated maze in in in the Corn
Belt so so I'm not going to that's all
I'm going to talk about for the
irrigated again because that was been
presented and actually that work has
been submitted and for public for
publications under review right now so
this is kind of a summary of the
precipitation and grain yields over time
for for the rain fed any and just for to
contrast I have the irrigated here so
the main main thing to note with the
precipitation is you know pretty steady
but 2012 was a very very low precip era
by mid-june or so precip shut down and
there was very little after that
particularly in in in the Western Corn
Belt
this was associated with very high
temperatures and very high BPD's I'll
explain a bit more about that no impact
on the irrigated yields is like I just
mentioned in fact 2012 was the highest
yield highest yielding year of the
period that we looked at and this period
included I should I didn't show the
temperature data but this period
included quite a broad range of
temperatures so both higher and lower
the rain fed yields are here so you'll
note I think anybody who's we're kind of
a somewhat aware of grain yields will
note that they're pretty high so you get
it's important to keep in mind this is a
yield contest so these growers are
selecting their best sites so even where
there maybe it's you know a
precipitation it may be getting to the
edge of the of the of the kind of rain
fed production agriculture you're still
selecting very varied their their best
sites so there's going to it's going to
maybe shift the yields a little bit
higher than what they would be normally
but 2012 there was a reduction in this
reduction the percentage reduction in
yields in these yield contest data is
pretty much the same as what the overall
reduction in you were in the Midwest in
2012 reported in the national
agricultural statistics so even though
the absolute values are higher the
magnitude of reduction 2012 was was
about the same and I'm going to focus on
2012 because of the the climate extremes
have that occur in that year so this is
kind of some summary data and most of
what I'm going to show us descriptive
because we're still in the preliminary a
part of this and these analyses the top
panel is grain yield as a function of
vapor pressure deficit this is for rain
fed for Kansas Missouri Nebraska so you
note that there is does appear to be a
relationship where whereby at higher
BPD's you do get lower yields important
to keep in mind though that the there's
a there's correlations among the climate
variables here and we'll get to that so
you would so it's not a maybe so much of
a surprise that the statistical modeling
that's been done might show that BPD is
a factor in impacting maize yields but I
think what we'll try to show is that
it's much more complicated than that we
look at Iowa I was interesting the rain
fed data same thing grain field as a
function of vapor pressure deficit there
was really no no impact partly because
the climate was not as severely impacted
in 2012 as it was in in in the Western
Corn Belt so we never got the really
high BPD's low proof as low precipitous
high temperatures this is the irrigated
as a as a comparison shows that when you
eliminate water stress there's no impact
of vapor pressure deficit or high
temperature on yields so getting to this
correlation that I've been mentioning so
this is this is the kind of combined
data from for all the yield data for the
rain fed with 2005 to 2012 showing the
season average team acts as a function
of season average vapor pressure deficit
and you can see clearly there's a
relationship higher the temperature the
higher the vapor pressure deficit
there's a color code here for precip for
June July and August total preset you'll
note that the higher precip Tsar in at
the lower VP DS lower temperatures as
you get to these higher values because
that's where the lower precipitation is
occurring so again important to keep you
know this this is important to know so
it makes it more difficult to identify
these drivers this is another way of
looking at where we plotted grain yield
as a function of growing season
precipitation where we color coded for
vapor pressure deficit here so darker
colors are
iron vapor pressure deficits so you note
up into about down to about 300
millimeters of of June July August
precip yields are scattered but they're
not but they're all fairly high but
about 300 and lower you get quite a
range of yields and you start getting
some very low yields these are in
particular where the very highest vapor
pressure deficits are were recorded this
was interesting these were interesting
data because of the large range and i'll
try to explain why you might at least
what we is one factor that might be
responsible while you're getting very
high yields but also very low yields
here but again just pointing out this
correlation among these climate factors
that are important in determining maize
productivity so I didn't I was going to
present some data initial data on them
statistical modeling that Liz is done
but I decided not to because I felt like
it I wasn't confident enough of my
knowledge of that modeling to do that
but I did want to present one thing one
first to note that in the modeling that
she's done so far all the climate
factors were significant so vpd
precipitation temperature and the
temperature thresholds that we looked at
the indices that we looked at all came
out to be having significant impact on
on maize yields the biggest impact
though interestingly enough was planting
rate and my interpretation of that is
that what what it appeared to be is that
in the yield contests the growers were
were actually too conservative in their
planting rate well we found we looked at
the rain fed data for the four states we
looked at is that under all scenarios
are there all vapor pressure deficits
you did better by increasing your
planting rate so you've got higher
yields no matter whether it was
no matter at what epd I think again this
comes back to the fact that these music
on in these contests they're paid for
picking their best sites so these sites
are going to have a maximum water
holding capacity I'll water holding
capacity I think date for 2012 in that
year they were just able to add enough
stored soil water to produce a pretty
good yield that's my kind of
interpretation but we're still analyzing
these data but again note that even add
very high planting rates you know that's
where you got your maximum yield at all
day pressure deficits I should say that
you know we're focused on rain-fed mays
here and humid production human region
production this is not dry land
production drilling and production the
recommendations for planting radar much
lower than then what were showing here
in part that's two for I think two for
the for the because the growers tend to
be risk-averse but also the the seed
companies are predicting or protecting
but prescribing lower planting rates in
part because they don't want to have the
onus of having a total crop failure but
that's not what we're talking about
we're talking about rain-fed humid
region production here so a couple of
the problems that that that was she
settling on the appropriate methodology
for variable selection and co efficient
estimation or modeling to statistical
modeling the problem that she's had is
the correlation that I just mentioned on
the climate variables but also that
there's a spatial correlation between
management and climate variables and
that's Liz's I think getting to a point
where we're close right it's been a long
process but she's done an excellent job
on
so I'll move on to the second question
which is this gets back to the VP DS is
there evidence to support this
assumption of high BP DS in the Corn
Belt under climate change it's really
out of my out of my waters here but this
is what I'm understanding is is
occurring precipitation most of the
precipitation for the US corn belt comes
from systems coming out of the Gulf of
Mexico they come up the Mississippi
Valley and they and produce rainfall
when that doesn't there are occasions
though where you get these episodic
droughts this occurs when a high
pressure system embeds in the Midwest it
blocks the transport of precipitation of
these systems up from the Gulf of Mexico
and this has occurred in 1983 1988 and
then as I've been talking quite a bit
about in 2012 the sequence of events is
important here because what what as far
as I understand from the literature the
main instigators reduce precipitation so
there's less rainfall this reduces
regional evapotranspiration that means
that more the incoming slow erations
getting partitioned to sensible heat
which not atmospheric heating let's say
higher temperatures and these higher
temperatures lead to the higher vapor
pressure deficits so the real instigator
is not that there are going to be higher
vapor pressure deficits as a blanket you
know it's a blanket statement for all
future climates it's only going to be
during these episodic droughts and the
instigator is going to be reduced
precipitation it is unclear whether
these episodic droughts events where you
have these high-pressure systems
embedding in there in the region whether
it be more or less likely to occur with
climate change I did think it was
interesting that one of the candidate
for the geospatial position Nathan
Mueller from his work the prediction was
that this they will not be more frequent
that in fact it's likely to be higher
precipitations precipitation total
precipitation during the growing season
in the in the Midwest but that they're
still on some uncertainty about that so
we respect to whether they'll be higher
VP DS I think based on this I would say
it's not if they're out if they are
higher they're not going to be
significantly higher and the only time
you'll get them is during these episodic
droughts so then they'll move on to the
kind of the third question is can we
what can we say about the impact of
climate on key processes in maize and
for this I'm going to move more into a
little more in depth on the impact on on
on the crop in particular focus on the
diurnal dynamics of of
evapotranspiration in particular not so
much on carbon assimilation although we
did that look at diurnal dynamics at the
field level of those processes in
relation to temperature and vapor
pressure deficits or evaporator demand
so the way I'm going to do that is by by
talking about work that we've done using
fluxed our data and eddy covariance
methodology to look at fluxes of so
latent heat flux or evapotranspiration
and sensible heat fluxes in other words
heating and then in with additional data
look at some some other things including
changes in canopy temperature changes in
aerodynamic conductance I won't talk
about that but that's one of the key
factors that is is is involved but then
in particular focus on canopy
conductance
as a function of these climate variables
diurnal e and at the field level we
mainly focused on America's towers in
Meade Nebraska and we looked at the
irrigated maize towers and all explain a
little bit why we did that we also had a
tower in Aurora ourselves in Aurora last
year which actually produced quite good
data I won't be getting to those data I
just don't have time so I'll focus
mostly on the mead data so this is
hopefully going to help set up a little
bit of what I'm what I'm going to talk
about when we're talking about these
fluxes latent heat and sensible heat
fluxes the amount of energy coming into
a field to the surface of the canopy is
the the described here is incoming solar
minus reflected ray solar radiation plus
the difference between long wave and
long wave out work we're calling that
the net radiation so that's total energy
coming into the top of the canopy that
energy has to be dissipated somehow in
order to balance the equation it can
either be lost as evapotranspiration or
it can be lost as sensible heat sensible
heat just means you have an object at a
higher temperature and a lower
temperature and it's the energy transfer
from the higher temperature to the lower
temperature when we're talking about a
crop it's almost always during sunlight
hours means the temperature the canopy's
higher and we're transferring energy
from that canopy to a lower temperature
atmosphere so the way you can think of
how the crop impacts is so they're so so
there are two factors a that affect how
this energies partition between
evapotranspiration and sensible
plus one is VPD so that will affect it
higher VP DS will shift it more towards
evapotranspiration less toward sensible
heat loss but the plan has control over
that through crop conductance so so I
had higher crop conductances you have
the same effect a shift towards more
evapotranspiration under any given set
of conditions at lower crop condense
conductances in other words like under
water stress you shift the energy is
shifted more towards sensible heat loss
in other words the canopy heats up so I
hope that that helps a little bit when I
talk in the next few slides but another
thing to note is that globally about
eighty percent of the net radiation is
dissipated through evapotranspiration so
that when we're talking about increases
in temperature increases an evaporative
demand there's a limit set by the amount
of incoming energy as to how much can be
shifted how much more evapotranspiration
can occur if you look at this example if
we're at we're averaging around six
millimeters per day of
evapotranspiration where eighty percent
and that represents eighty percent of
the total net radiation the most you can
get most increase in that that you can
get is about to 7.5 millimeters per day
so there's a real limit so it's not like
you know you can you just are capped by
the incoming energies that's an
important thing to keep in mind so
here's some kind of just to look at some
of the dining diurnal dynamics in kind
of broad terms these are data from from
one of the Americs towers at Meade to
showing a typical kind of diurnal
sequence of of changes are this kind of
oranges bars and the incoming net
radiation the green is the
evapotranspiration or latent heat and
the red is sensible heat this is for
well watered canopy so you can see that
most of the incoming net radiation is
accounted for in by evapotranspiration
and very little by sensible heat
transfer one thing to note is the blue
dashed line is a favorite pressure
deficit so the key thing to note is that
the highest vapor pressure deficits are
actually occurring later in the day when
net radiations low evapotranspiration
slow that we'll come back to that in the
bed so this is what this is a kind of a
typical water stress canopy then same
incoming net radiation but because we're
beginning to get stomata closure or
reduction prop conductance the shift in
partitioning of that energy is now more
to sensible heat and less to latent heat
or less to evaporative
evapotranspiration so what's the what's
the impact the impact is that we look at
air temperature versus canopy
temperature for that water stress
example we're now getting canopy
temperatures that are significantly
above air temperature and will I'll
explain more about that then so this is
these are data from the mead tower
towers for irrigated maze for 2010 11
and 12 so you might wonder why we're
using irrigated data here when we're I'm
talking about rain in part on about rain
fed maze it just so happened
fortuitously for us but maybe not for
them so much that in 2012 they basically
weren't able to keep up with the
irrigation so they actually had
essentially a deficit irrigation they
were getting water stress in their crop
and so that actually turned out nicely
because we were not able to get rain fed
data from those towers in 2012 they
didn't they were in a soy bean maze
rotation and
that year they happen to be in soybean
for the for the rain fed towers so the
first thing to note is you know what we
what we see here is vapor pressure
deficits over the course of the day this
is for the for the growing season this
from canopy closure to the beginning of
senescence so it's time when there's a
full canopy but no senescence these are
the compiled data over that time for the
different hours here so the vapor
pressure deficits remain fairly low
during the two years where there was
good irrigation is we're not and they
were not drought years during 2012 like
we've been talking about the day pradesh
vapor pressure deficits increased
considerably and and again that had we
saw that earlier in some of the data
that we showed from for the yield
contest so this is an interesting
because this shows latent heat
evapotranspiration as a fret as a
fraction net radiation over time for
these for the same three years so keep
in mind net radiation is approximately
equal to latent heat plus sensible heat
or evapotranspiration transformation
plus sensibly so you can see through
most of the day we're at about point
eight so that's about was i was pointing
out before globally about eighty percent
of the net radiation is accounted for by
by evapotranspiration and that's pretty
in words so this is pretty consistent
with us and that occurred in all three
years but note later in the day this is
when the vp DS are increasing we do see
an increase in all three years in the
fraction of net radiation that's
accounted for by evapotranspiration and
it goes up again in all three years what
was interesting is that is 2012 so in
2012 that actually went above the ratio
went above one
so how can that be well that happens
because the canopy is actually being
cooled to the point where there is now
the sensible heat flux is reversed
you're actually getting pre heat
transfer or energy transfer from the
atmosphere to the canopy the question is
from a kind of a production standpoint
with respect to these drought periods is
is is this a good thing we're losing
water here and it's and it's occurring
at a time when net radiation is going
down there's not that much
photosynthesis crop photosynthesis is
actually declined pretty pretty pretty
steeply than what if we were able to
stop this could weeks conserve water in
these drought years and potentially you
know get a higher yield under those
conditions and I'll come back to that
but that's something to consider what
was always so this is shows the crop
conductance and it shows that so this is
a typical pattern that we see for
well-watered crop conductance over over
the period of the day so 2011 2011-2012
was lower by the time crop canopy
closure occurred in this system in these
in these fields there are the drought
was already in place they were not
keeping up with the irrigation so we
were already seeing evidence of that by
lower crop conductances in 2012 so even
though conductance is going down you
think would be within reduced
evapotranspiration the very high VP DS
that we saw earlier here we're we're
high enough to counteract that and
create you know actually result in this
where we were getting evapotranspiration
at such a high rate that we're actually
getting canopy cooling so and this this
this shows what the kind of net result
of that is is that instead of showing
that and said that canopy being much
higher than air temperature then
the temperatures that we see in the
irrigator it actually was being
maintained pretty close to those and
really not in a range where we'd expect
any temperature impact is so is this a
good thing you might argue that it's
better to keep temperatures it's better
to lose a little bit of water and keep
those temperatures canopy temperatures a
little cooler if your main concern is
temperature your main concern is water
you might go the other way and say well
let's have some more stomata closure and
and will sacrifice the little higher
temperatures but we'll save some water
so this shows just kind of a kind of a
summary grapplers looking at
evapotranspiration in millimeters per
hour as a function of a pressure deficit
color codes the same we have blue for
2010 green for 2011 and red for 2012 so
the thing to note here and this gets
back to how much total
evapotranspiration can occur when you're
tapped by the amount of energy limited
by the amount of energy coming in you
can see that at about 2 KP a vapor
pressure deficit basically you can't
transpire any more water that's kind of
it you can see the impact of the lower
conductance in 2012 in that at any given
vpd we're getting higher evaporates in
2010 and 2011 but you'll see at the
higher highest VP DS we are that was our
occurring in 2012 and we're seeing those
out here there's quite a scatter of
points here and I'll show this in a bit
but this is because net radiation is
going down at the time the highest BPD's
are occurring and so you're actually
getting even though you're at a maximum
or above that you know the
evapotranspiration as a fraction that
radiation is actually above 1 the total
amount water loss is actually not that
hot
so now I'll get to the last question
which is this issue what what do you
want to do in terms of trying to to
improve crops improve maize hybrids for
these episodic droughts and what pioneer
is has opted to do in their breeding is
to come out with so-called drought
tolerant varieties and those droughts
all on varieties one of the it's clear
that one of the traits that has been
introduced is the that they have made
them sensitive to vapor pressure deficit
so above a certain vapor pressure
deficit its stomata begin to close and
the idea is you're conserving water
during those drought years so that you
have enough water to get a decent yield
at the end of the growing season and
these are so I'm calling these kind of
reduced transpiration hybrids so they've
opted for the water conservation and not
for any impact that there might be on as
a result of that on temperature so this
shows some some modeling results to that
were from a paper and journal of
experimental botany by pot of the
pioneer folks primarily to try to
demonstrate what the value of this trait
might be they have their drought
tolerant drought sensitive is the dash
looking at changes in soil moisture over
the growing season and you'll see that
early on with this trait of reduced
transpiration trait there was less water
extracted from the profile and more
water towards the end of the growing
season on the drought tolerant pulled
out drought tolerant variety when they
looked at total biomass and yield with
this in this modeling exercise you'll
see that uppit to a certain point they
were both the same but then late in the
season because the more available water
deeper in the hole in the soil profile
with a drought talk that fry was able to
use that
to produce more yield and more total
biomass so what we did just to kind of
take a quick look at this was we did a
modeling exercise where we looked at
your Kansas in 2012 a very again very
hot very dry period and we looked at two
scenarios one was where we had crop
conductance independent of April
pressure deficit and one where we
allowed it to be dependent on vapor
pressure deficit based on data from a
paper that was used as one of the kind
of a kind of foundations for this
introducing this trade into these
droughts taller varieties or transfer
sensitive reduced transpiration
varieties so the first thing is the
total amount of VT that occurred with
when it was independent was 217
millimeters over this month versus 182
millimeters when you have made this crop
conductance dependent on BPG so it does
save water at least based on our our our
work here if you look at
evapotranspiration hourly as a function
of a pressure deficit these kind of we
saw this just just a few slides
previously showing a kind of a calf
around 2k PA what's interesting is the
blue hour for 3 p.m. red or 1 2 3 p.m.
and the green are after 3pm so this just
illustrates said even though the vp DS
were very high later the total amount of
water loss was not as high as earlier
because the net radiation was lower so
this is for the independent where crop
conductance is independent of a
professor deficit where it's dependent
we actually cap this at a lower et rain
so at around seven millimeters
this point seven millimeters per hour so
we get the we get the savings of water
and that's a that's a good thing if
you're in an F and you want to have
you're willing to sacrifice may be a
little bit yield in the really good
years but you're going to get more yield
in the dryer dryer yours the problem is
here is his temperature so in this
scenario we had air temperature we
looked at canopy temperature with no VPD
dependence and canopy canopy temperature
where there was a dependence of crop
conductance on BPD I've got a little
screwed up here but the the air
temperature over that period the maximum
air temperature was around 37 see no VPD
dependence the canopy temperature was
around 38 degrees C when you hadn't made
a BP dependent you were saving water the
result was you increase your canopy
temperature so the question is what do
you want you if you you have this trait
you'll save water but you're going to
get higher canopy canopy temperatures
you're going to start getting KMP
temperatures presumably it to the into
the yes
yep
well I did what they did when they they
looked at a large range of genotypes in
this in this initial work that was done
on this and they just did was brought
chamber work and looked at imposing
different vapor pressure deficits and at
what point did they begin to get a shift
in transpiration indicating a
sensitivity of stomata to vapor pressure
deficit a lot of genotypes didn't show
that response but there were some that
did so that kind of apparently was a
foundation for moving to to to trying to
include this trade into the into the
hybrids so again you know you can save
water but you but you potentially are
pushing canopy temperatures pretty high
paper just recently came out in crop
science where this day you know there
was some recognition of the problem with
this and so what they've tried to
identify and they pin think they have
identified our hybrids that are
sensitive to vpd so they shut down or
they reduce transpiration at higher
BPD's but at a certain temperature they
lose that and they begin to open up and
so they've been too cool at around and
this seems to be around 38 degrees C I I
mean now that needs to be looked into
because what I've tried to point out is
these hi BBD sclera coincide with
droughts so the stomata are already
responding to a crop law to a soil
moisture stress I don't know how much
more this trait you know this this this
how this might interact with what we
know is already going on but that's that
was interesting that there begun to be
recognition that this could be a
potentially serious issue here so that's
just a very brief and very kind of
cursory overview of what we're doing and
we hope to be able to continue this work
particularly extend its statistical
modeling
include other regions and also do more
work on our eddy covariance and crop
growth modeling looking more into these
interactions between the climate and the
crop I want to acknowledge the group I
mentioned before and these other folks
for all the work all the input that they
provided for us in particular any
Schweiker at need for the mare flux data
Paul Stankowski and staff at musgrave
for the flux tower a couple folks at
pioneer for information on their
cultivars and Tim for some helpful
discussions and that's our flux tower
from last year and rora some thanks
question on
Oh
and
as far as I know they're not
they
one behind himself
we gave what is all yields and range so
it's not like your saves you don't get
what yakima Moscow
is important either one or the bestest
bud
my understanding
muscle
is that
porn
plastic so it's
graph if you are a drug addict on
probation
then
I'm surprised that you
stressed
well so do you increase the stress
critical time
I think the
reading such that
I did show this graph reading such a
rise that show this are still are still
performing well there goes flood water
in and
you
the response was so great that you were
shutting down for since
I don't think we're talking about a big
big difference not talking about because
he's a separate
so it's not like
we're tight on the 30
so this line
imposing
it's not no thing it's a spread
significant stress in monitoring
he was a very significant loss it was
very
strong productions
what is it
the graphic shows
regulate that and it would
is probably times
yeah well I mean that was waters causing
matters that the insured is what was
interesting about that
look at the Harvey change it actually
wasn't all that much in that person look
in all three years in fact
so even though it shows responsive
that's actually enough
it shows the beta version
say that
it was counterintuitive to me and I
wonder if you can
without a retouch rod another doubters
that love when immensely suffers more no
it doesn't
people were looking at is quality of the
site so i think these sites there's not
not seeing as my notes
work here
so I think we're fighting about really
good
or you keep that
seven so actually they were these fries
were losing you bye listen we're not
hitting plants out or optimum density
for that so they can put more planes
lonely off
would think that would be the case what
we need even beginning you go down
planets go down to not let say underpass
no no so now the plants after thousands
their maintained per client yields even
as he podido seems to me
push that's again my interpretation that
is that is real contest of animals
that's best one this applies some of
this correlation or a relationship is
driven by non independence between
planting density in the end of
innovation yep people with eating
disorders they planted
the lower densities were more in the
western part where there were hiring
could you also say that at low Clinton
densities at low Clinton densities if
the plants are not under VPD spread
stress they can kind of compensate but
if they are actually actually we're
looking I get issue of lower planning
against how much are you actually state
you know
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu